-Performing
"More Pressure" and "Grace"
from their upcoming album,
"The Line is a Curve,"
please welcome Kae Tempest.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[Rapping] ♪ More pressure,
more release ♪
♪ More relief,
more belief ♪
♪ More distance
more reach ♪
♪ The truth is I don't know,
it's so deep ♪
♪ I know nothing
I used to think ♪
♪ Things were so clear ♪
♪ I was so near to nowhere ♪
♪ I could feel everything
in me ♪
♪ Pushing for certains,
but certains are flimsy ♪
♪ Rock-solid ground
beneath me now ♪
♪ Tells me there's no ground
at all ♪
♪ More pressure,
more release ♪
♪ Your eyes, your cheeks ♪
♪ Your features crease ♪
♪ More desire,
less deceit ♪
♪ Less complex,
more complete ♪
♪ Less push,
more flow ♪
♪ Please, let me let go ♪
♪ Get it all out of you,
let it surprise you ♪
♪ I was in a party,
face mostly eyeballs ♪
♪ Chin deep
in a bag of white lies ♪
♪ Saying I'm sick and tired of
my own advice ♪
♪ I see it now,
so perfect ♪
♪ But so hard
to put into practice ♪
♪ One step forwards,
two steps backwards ♪
♪ One soul's epiphany's
another soul's madness ♪
♪ I saw the truth in the curls
of the vanishing girl ♪
♪ Hands like cobwebs dangling ♪
♪ Eyes like deep sea dives ♪
♪ She said stop worrying, man ♪
♪ Stop panicking ♪
♪ Calmer ♪
♪ Clearer ♪
♪ Closer ♪
♪ Nearer ♪
♪ More grounded ♪
♪ More rooted ♪
♪ Less convoluted ♪
♪ More stillness,
more movement ♪
♪ More existence ♪
♪ Less improvement ♪
♪ More decisions ♪
♪ Less solutions ♪
♪ Less inhibition ♪
♪ Less confusion ♪
♪ More intuition ♪
♪ More connection ♪
♪ More nature ♪
♪ More protection ♪
♪ More abundance ♪
♪ More reflection,
less instruction ♪
♪ More comprehension ♪
♪ More pressure,
more release ♪
♪ More relief,
more belief ♪
♪ More distance,
more reach ♪
♪ The truth is I don't know,
it's so deep ♪
♪ More pressure,
more release ♪
♪ More relief,
more belief ♪
♪ Less push,
more flow ♪
♪ Please, let me let go ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ It was grace ♪
♪ Stunned by the last lights
of the sun ♪
♪ We were swimming in
a green sea as deep as a drum ♪
♪ And there are things I must
record, must praise ♪
♪ Things I have to say about
the fullness and the blaze ♪
♪ Of this beautiful life ♪
♪ The beloved watched
the world on its knees ♪
♪ With an infinite degree
of separation ♪
♪ That was something to see ♪
♪ And my friend told me ♪
♪ Death is like taking off
a tight shoe ♪
♪ And when I stopped looking for
me, I was able to find you ♪
♪ Right there,
where everything is ♪
♪ Transcendent ♪
♪ I feel myself opening up,
getting closer ♪
♪ No hope is enough ♪
♪ I've stopped hoping,
I'm learning to trust ♪
♪ I came to under
that red moon ♪
♪ And I was completely crushed ♪
♪ So please use me ♪
♪ Please through me,
please unscrew me ♪
♪ Please, loosen me up ♪
♪ Please make music
with me ♪
♪ Make everything stop ♪
♪ Make noise and make silence
with me ♪
♪ Make love, let me be love,
let me be loving ♪
♪ Let me give love, receive
love, and be nothing but love ♪
♪ In love, and for love,
and with love ♪
♪ And love said, if you bring
forth what is within you ♪
♪ What you bring forth
will save you ♪
♪ But if you do not bring forth
what is within you ♪
♪ What you do not bring forth ♪
♪ Will destroy you ♪
♪ So let me be love,
let me be loving ♪
♪ Let me give love, receive
love, and be nothing but love ♪
♪ In love, and for love,
and with love ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]